So let's go through them 1 by 1.
Finding a polynomial-time algorithm for an NP-compete problem, yes.
That would show that P=NP because the problem is NP-complete.
So it means it's among the hardest-to-solve problems in NP.
So polynomial-time algorithm for this problem will solve
any other NP-complete problem in polynomial time as well.
Finding an algorithm that solves an NP-complete problem
in polynomial time on average.
Now, that's a very interesting one, because you might be inclined to think,
"Well, if it solves an NP-complete problem
in polynomial time on average, then probably that is sufficient."
Well, it shows a lot of interesting things, but it doesn't show anything
with respect to P being = to NP, or P being ≠ to NP.
Now, showing that the most efficient algorithm for clique requires exponential time,
that would show that P≠NP.
Because clique is contained in NP, so if it requires exponential time,
it means that there's at least 1 problem, namely clique, that is contained in NP but not in P.
Of course, as nice as it would be to show this, of course,
it would also be quite difficult to prove this because you would have to show that,
again, no matter what algorithm you come up with,
it always requires exponential time.
That would be hard to do because you would have to consider any algorithm,
even algorithms that haven't been invented yet, so to say.
Now, showing that vertex cover has an exponential number of potential solutions,
that is similar to the example I pointed out to you in the beginning of this unit,
namely, that just having an exponential number of potential solutions
does not mean that the problem is hard.
It can mean that the problem is hard, but as you've seen
in the case of shortest path, it's not necessarily so.
Now, reducing clique to shortest path versus reducing shortest path to clique,
then you have to remember again what reduction means.
So if you reduce clique to shortest path, it means that solving the shortest path problem
is also capable of also solving the clique problem.
And since shortest path is solvable in polynomial time,
if you manage to reduce clique to shortest path,
that would show that P=NP.
If, on the other hand, you manage to reduce shortest path to clique,
that doesn't really have any implications
because all you've shown is that shortest path is an easier problem than clique,
which is something we already know.
Now if you look at all of these solutions, well, of course, it's a bit of
a subjective selection here, but what you'll see,
that showing that P=NP in a way would be quite easy.
All you have to do is find 1 single polynomial-time algorithm for an NP-complete problem.
Then you have immediately shown that P=NP.
On the other hand, if you want to show that P≠NP, then you have to put in a lot of work,
because you have to consider any possible algorithm,
no matter how complex, how intelligent, how sophisticated,
and still somehow make the case that this algorithm is not able
to solve a problem like clique in polynomial time.